joining us here from monday night
football and one of the best analysts in
all the land talking ball we'd love to
do this with espn's louis reddick back
here in the rich eisen show how are you
sir
better question i'm good man how are you
i'm better i'm better thank god good to
hear thank you
really appreciate that lewis thank you
absolutely let's jump into it which uh
which um performance from this weekend
um sticks with you the most
louis riddick you know what man
honestly
all of them
stick with me because i really do think
this draft class has the potential to be
special
as long as the teams that they want to
do their work and make sure that they
take care of these young players
bring them along at the proper speed
bring them along with the
with the level of confidence of the
coaching staff that is necessary for
these guys to reach their potential
i mean
these guys
honestly i know it's the first preseason
game but look i was very impressed by
their body language their poise
some of the big plays they did hit i
think you know right out of the gate
look i know how complicated new
england's offense is
and what mack was able to do
particularly in the second half of their
of their preseason game as far as going
hurry up no huddle calling plays at the
line of scrimmage changing protections
running that sophisticated passing game
i thought that was i thought that was
special
justin obviously had a lot of fanfare
going into his his uh
appearance in chicago and i think that
athleticism was on display the unique
play-making ability outside the pocket
was on display
right out of the gate
zach wilson
he just looks like he belongs and i
understand like you're a jet fan you
understand what the expectation is
they they want a hero so bad
in new york and i think again
as long as they do right by the kid and
take care of the other 52 spots in the
rest of the organization
he's going to be good to go i just
listened to this you know trey lance
talked to you before before he was
drafted
i went up to north dakota i was up in
fargo for his pro day i got a chance to
spend some time with him
that kid is flat out unique he's a
unicorn as a person
he's a star as a person
he went to the perfect place
you saw the potential that he has
i saw people making some big deals out
of some of the you know some of his
statistics outside of the big
play he hit for a touchdown people
realize now he had three drops that were
absolute dimes right on the money
receivers his flat out drop
he's going to be he's going to be good
you're going to see him sooner rather
than later and trevor lawrence
he starts all fumbling the football
and then he's standing in the pocket
looking like
a big tall rookie dan marino just i mean
i'm just saying body type wise poi
delivery the way the ball jumps out of
his hands you know the kind of velocity
these kids man
but i'll tell you what
and i know
this it's early okay
but this is the fun part for me the
projection part of this yep
quarterbacks fail a lot of players fail
i think more players fail in the nfl
because people don't do but do right by
them
organizationally
and i think this group right here all of
them have the potential to be special
and more and i think what will determine
the success failure of these kids absent
some kind of bone-headed decision they
make off the field or some kind of freak
injury
is the organization's messing them up
because i think these guys
have the potential to be one of those
draft classes like we talk about the
2004 draft class like we talked about
the great draft class i believe what was
that 83
that we that that's
they had the potential that 10 15 years
from now we're talking about this class
that way
if these organizations take care of them
lewis riddick here on the rich eisen
show of course now the the ultimate
question is the when when do we see them
you know uh even though again i'm i'm
genuinely nervous that trevor lawrence
might not be
doing enough to be named the starter in
jacksonville
so he could just place him aside uh you
know zach wilson is going to get the gig
right from jump there's no question
about that
the other guys okay
with jimmy garoppolo being in san
francisco and having already taken this
team to a super bowl and i understand
you could say that others took them but
he was the quarterback of that team and
then you've got also uh in new england
with cam newton sitting there and if
anybody's sitting here well how's
belichick gonna what a tough decision
for belichick and belichick's like uh
how about brady and bledsoe holding my
beer on that front so let's place that
one aside as well the one that
fascinates me is chicago because dalton
is new there it's it's not like he's got
any sort of skin in the game in that
locker room with with the his teammates
and fields looked the way that he did if
he does that against the bills even
against against the bills twos i
understand that's a tough assignment
against the rams on a sunday night on
nbc with donald and ramsey but
what do you think about field starting
week one the bears just just ripping the
band-aid off and just going what do you
think of that idea louis you know rich i
think it'll be
it wouldn't be shocking and i don't
necessarily feel as though
it would be
you know i understand why you use the
analogy i don't necessarily feel as
though it'll be ripping the band-aid off
because of this
people want to make a lot about the fact
or a lot out of the fact that matt
maggie the head coach his
his uh
job status at the end of this year could
be in question or upper review however
you want to term it
no kid he knows that
so what i mean he gets that we all we
all get that we're all up for review
he
knowing him like i do
is not making his decision for justin
based off of that
he
truly is if you know matt maggie you
know his story and how he came up and
how he came into this league and how he
got his start
this is about as genuine a guy as i know
and i know him pretty damn well he wants
to do right by justin
he wants this young man to be that
quarterback for the city of chicago that
they basically have never had
and they i mean and that's why i think
of all the quarterbacks everyone is so
enamored with that situation because of
him being drafted by a blue blood team
that of all the great players that
they've had they've never had that
quarterback that one
so
if justin can prove to him that given
some of the deficiencies that they have
particularly on the offensive line
remember now they decided jason peters
that's a poor reason
because their offensive tackles are not
good and matt knows it and ryan pace
knows it and everybody who watches
football knows it
if he feels as though justin can protect
himself
from a protection standpoint making sure
he's got the guys covered up that he
needs to have covered up that he's able
to protect himself against free rushers
when teams try to blitz his brains out
if he is in the game which is what they
will do
then he will put him in there and i
don't that could be week one if he feels
it's comfortable if he feels he's ready
it could be week four it could be week
eight
he really is not basing this on anything
other than
when is he ready to go
when can it be one of those where then
the trajectory is a spare step up
and
i think we all as football fans in the
city of chicago for damn sure
would like for it to be week one
because we saw we we all saw what he
just did we saw we see the electric
athleticism
but matt truly rich is trying to make
this decision about the long term about
being great not just now but being great
forever for justin not being able to
just win now and this team be able to
win now but for justin to be able to win
forever and for this team to be set up
for a long time forever in the future he
really is and i believe that
i really do believe it it's just a
matter of
how does this thing trend over the next
two to three weeks
and justin's gonna control that and
i i i believe that organically speaking
that's how he's gonna do it
personally
i'm selfish just like everyone else i
want to see him week one sure because
because the kid is a freak man
and all the stuff about the is he
committed to being great if he's willing
to go the extra the whole scouting axiom
up is he first in and last out is he
doesn't really get rid of all the
distractions is he all football the time
i'm i'm telling you
i know matt again very well
it has been all business from day one
and the kid has heard all of this he's
heard people question him about all of
this and from all accounts in chicago
he is about as lasered in as you could
possibly be
and
i i really do think
they've got something special going on
there man
um
look again the fan in me hopes that he
plays right off the right out of the
gate me too right out of the gate me too
lewis reddick here on the rich eisen
show and
you know and sometimes i also think you
know
from my own experience it can be over
thought too you know and again i'm not
there as you point out i'm not there in
meeting rooms i'm not there you know in
weight rooms i'm not there you know um
in in in any way shape or form boots on
the ground so i'm sitting here i'm
sitting wherever i am looking in it on
this and with my own experiences you
know and
and everybody's their own individual i
just remember the way that desean watson
got his first start he got his first
start because his coach put him in the
middle of a game in week one
and and then got the start the next week
on a short week in cincinnati when you
want to talk about lack of protection
they were they were down to tight ends
being thrown on the offensive line due
to concussions and all sorts of stuff
and watson was in cincinnati i saw with
my own two eyes he ran it in from
midfield for a touchdown which was the
only touchdown of the game against andy
dalton i might add they got the win and
all of a sudden desean watson is born in
the nfl and i'm wondering why not give
that a whirl for justin fields is what
i'm pretty much sitting here thinking
and you know what i mean that's a great
argument that's a great argument for it
um
[Music]
there's no perfect there's no there's no
way of knowing
with 100 degree 100 100
certainty right if justin would have the
same fate so to speak right we don't
know that and they they have to take
their best guess or their most educated
guess as to whether or not that would be
the case if they did that with him and i
mean we don't know i mean we can i can
give you examples of quarterbacks who
came into the league
i can give you one right i mean who get
their heads beat in right and they're
never they're not the same it's just
they just start seeing ghosts man and
just do because look as a guy who plays
defense and you're around great players
all the time with what you do rich and
you know
the defensive players are kooky man
they're trying to they're trying to put
quarterbacks under the turf correct and
when they get hit like that and over and
over again i don't care what kind of guy
you are you start flinching that they
did he just doesn't want that to happen
to justin and we don't know if it will
or if it won't and i'm with you look his
athleticism
will probably be able to negate some of
those hits
and some of those you know some of those
scenarios where he'll be putting harm's
way behind that swiss cheese and
offensive line they got in chicago
obviously much better than what andy
dalton can and will give them a better
chance than what andy galton can i'm not
gonna i'm not a fool i'm not gonna argue
for andy dalton over justin fields if
justin has enough of a grasp of the
offense i'm just saying i really do
think that
you know
just as like
almost in like a like in a fatherly like
mentor way
matt has this has this affection for
this kid in a way that
kind of like almost almost transcends
football like he just wants this guy
to succeed in a way that no one at that
position has succeeded in chicago he
really has taken this on
in a personal way
and
he's seen he's seen how when you do it
just right he's seen how guys can become
the kind of guys that get half billion
dollar contract because he was in kansas
city when they did this with patrick
right so he understands it
we'll see what he does with it lewis
riddick here uh from espn monday night
football here on the rich eisen show um
what do you think starts for the saints
what do you think sean payton's thinking
going through after what he just saw
uh first preseason game packers uh in
his house to start week one what are
your thoughts on that subject
i as much as as much as sean has told
me and our monday night crew personally
when we talk to him that he believes
that taysom hill is the starting
quarterback in the nfl i have a hard
time believing that
when the whole evaluation is done and
all the reps have been logged that that
jamis does not come out on top there i
just have a hard time believing that
and
i'm going to stick with that based off
of what i saw on tape
in that first game which taysom started
off pretty hot and looked pretty good he
had some nice throws jameis had some
nice throws too jameis is a super super
talented quarterback
he really is who seems to have had
something click on in his head as far as
understanding look man i got to knock
some of this nonsense off as far as
putting my team
in jeopardy i have a hard time believing
he doesn't come out on top there if he
doesn't
you can you can count me in the
in the category of being just
knocked out of my fair shot
i think he's the quarterback opening
weekend what do you think belichick does
with his quarterback scenario
we
uh
i just know this i i don't know i mean
you you know man
you know as well that bill is about as
assassin
cold-hearted and calculated and
objective about this thing as as anybody
in the history of this business
i think
they know
that right now
mac is coming on strong
they know it
they they see it
they see it and look i was in cleveland
when bill
gave the old
bernie kosar diminishing skills press
conference i was there
i we all saw what he did to to drew
in new england
bill doesn't care
bill cares about about your feelings
bill cares about the bottom line
and
for them
to basically articulate that mac is
coming
i i think i think in the first within
the first month of that season of this
of this season
i think mac is starting and i you know i
said this
what great freaking theater would it be
that mac was starting against tom week
four yes sunday night football brady's
return
he's wearing brady's college number yeah
man it's just that was that would be a
great one and you know what i'm that's
what i'm hoping for me too and that's
nothing against cam because i know of
course you can't look i'm part of the
cam army all right i i love the guy
i i could not have had more fun talking
to a guy last year than cameron
but as cam said
they did the right thing he knows what's
happening he understands the business
it's a replacement business
that's what it is that's what the nfl is
a replacement business and he sees his
replacement and what a hell of a thing
that has to be man when you know like
this guy is there for that
that that's that's all that's still kind
of wild to me even having seen it happen
and been a part of it it's still just
kind of wild but um
i think we see mac
i think with i still will say within the
first
month of the season
he said i was reading reports here
before i came on here to talk to you
that
mac was throwing dimes in their joint
practices
30 miles from here you know in philly at
the nova care complex in their joint
practices that he was looking good there
so
so we see you and um greasy and big bag
of leaves steve levy in new orleans a
week from tonight jaguar saints is that
where you receive we sure do but we can
see us even sooner than that you'll see
us on friday friday night
yep
mahomes not pat patrick that's correct
let's do that because we know you've run
afoul of that before louis let's
let's get that all t's crossed and eyes
dotted and patrick
eric the enemy calls him pat nobody said
anything about it but you know it's all
good
you know and we get to see um and we get
to see hopefully we get to see kylo ren
yep yep and everybody yeah that's a good
game for us man that's a good game
friday night okay chiefs cardinals
friday night on the worldwide leader in
sports and then jaguars and saints again
i'll be on the edge of my seat to see if
trevor lawrence can win the job that
night every single day every single snap
you take care of yourself lewis i'm
gonna
look for my number throughout the season
quite a bit if you don't mind my man you
better take care of yourself i'm the
best you bet one of the best lewis
riddick hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here